JAMES GRIME: Welcome to our
first official video on our
new channel called Numberphile,
all about
different numbers.
We've decided to make out first
video on a very special
date, that's the 11th
of November 2011.
That's 11/11/11.
Or if you're American, that's
11/11/11, right?
So we've come to Nottingham
Forest Football Stadium, which
Brady insisted on.
11 football players in a team.
Personally, I more think of 11
Doctor Who's, but never mind.
And we've just come in
through Entrance 11.
If we walk this way up here to
row 11, and I'm going to sit
right here in seat number
11, so 11, 11, 11.
So guess what we're going
to talk about today?
BRADY HARAN: What?
JAMES GRIME: 11.
Yes, so recently we've had a
lot of dates with ones and
zeroes in them.
They're called binary days.
They're like binary numbers.
And this is the last binary
day until next century.
When Brady first asked me to
talk about the number 11,
especially for this date,
I was worried.
I thought, well, it's a prime
number, but I don't know what
else I could talk about.
And then I realized there's a
way that we use the number 11
every day, all the time.
We're going to use a book.
Now, you can do this yourself.
If you've got a book
nearby, grab it.
And here's my book, this is
Johnny Ball's Second Thinks.
Never leave home without it.
On the back of the book,
there's a bar code.
And next to the barcode,
there is an ISBN.
That's an International
Standard Book Number.
And that number is going to be
13 digits long, or it's going
to be 10 digits long.
Actually, I'm not interested
in the 13-digit number.
I want the 10-digit number.
Does your book have a 10-digit
number on the back?
Now, here's something you
can do with that number.
Let's write down my number
here on the back--
0140318194.
That's the ISBN number for
old Johnny Ball there.
Now, the first number here
actually tells you which
country the book
was published.
The next few numbers tell you
the name of the publisher.
The few numbers after that
is the book itself.
And the very last number is
called a check digit.
Let me show you something
you can do.
I'm going to take the first
digit, multiply it by 10.
OK, so 0 times 10.
That's quite easy, that's a 0.
The second digit there I'm
going to times by 9.
So 1 times 9.
Quite easy again, that's 9.
The third digit I
multiply by 8.
That's going to be
four times 8.
That's 32.
The next digit I times by
7, and that's another
easy one for me.
That's a 0.
And you can keep going.
And the very last digit
you multiply by 1.
So that's going to be 4 times
1, that's the number 4.
Now, what you do is you add
these together so you're going
to make a number.
It's going to be something
like 100, 200, 300,
that sort of size.
If I add these numbers
together-- and I've done this
already, I've done
this in my head.
If you add these numbers
together, you will get here
the number 121.
And this number is
a multiple of 11.
And it always will be.
If you try this yourself, you
will get a multiple of 11.
In this case, this was 11
squared, 11 times 11.
Whatever you get, it's going
to be a multiple of 11.
And they do this on purpose
so that they can detect if
there's been an error.
If you inputted the book code in
wrongly, if you swapped two
digits over by mistake,
it will be
able to detect a problem.
It's called an error
detection code.
The very last digit is chosen
so that this will work.
Now, the very last digit will be
a number between 0 and 10.
So for the first 9 digits,
that's not a problem.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
The very last digit, the number
10, well, we don't have
a single digit for a 10.
So instead, you may see the
letter X, which is the Roman
numeral for 10.
That's used for 10 instead.
So this part, well, that
could be anything that
they want it to be.
But this number is completely
engineered to make this work,
to make a multiple of 11.
If you have one of the 13-digit
book codes, they use
a slightly different
operation.
It's actually based on
the number 10 instead
of the number 11.
OK, so this is the view
from 11, 11, 11.
The number 11 is used for these
error correction codes.
But error correction code,
that idea is used
all over the place.
It's used with computers.
It's used with mobile
phones if you're
trying to send a message.
And, well, in transmission,
you can
lose some of the message.
So you want to be able to
reconstruct the message
without having to send
it all over again.
And you can do this yourself.
Again, this is with a CD.
And if you burn a CD, if you
hold it up to the light, you
can even see where
the tracks are.
And if you use a black pen here,
a black marker pen, I
could put a dot on this CD,
and this would represent
something like dirt
or a scratch.
And this will still play.
It can compensate for this
missing information.
Well, in a book code, we might
know there is a missing five.
There's something we can do.
In a CD, it uses a whole
equation with all sorts of
numbers, and you can use that
equation to work out which
number is missing
and what it is.
So we've done this with my CD
in my computer right now.
I'm going to play you a song,
a song all about numbers.
I thought it would be an
appropriate choice.
You can hear it does
still play.
If I pull it out, slightly more
dramatic than a black
marker pen.
We actually drilled a
hole through the CD.
So the data is actually
literally missing.
Not just a black mark, we
actually took out the data.
Yet the CD player can
reconstruct it and still play
the song because it will use
this error detection
technology, this mathematics
that reconstructs the missing
information.
In fact, this hole is
about 2 millimeters.
You can go up to about 2.5.
If I go even further, I've got
one here with 3 millimeters, a
3-millimeter hole.
This hole is too big.
Let's try it out.
I'm going to try and
play this as well.
You'll notice the difference.
[MUSIC SKIPPING]
It's trying.
It's trying its best.
It doesn't play.
Too much missing information.
So 11 was just our starting
point into a world of
mathematics and error correction
code, something
that is used everywhere that
makes your CD work, that makes
your mobile phone work, and, of
course, makes that number
on the back of a book work.
And Brady insists that I remind
you that, yes, it is
the number of players
in a football team.